[Music]
the worldwide covid-19 pandemic
highlighted that Health crises have no
borders so it's important that
information on the medical background of
a patient should be available to all
citizens and Healthcare professionals
wherever they are in Europe
the growing need for cross-border health
care in recent years has consequently
been a trigger in the adoption of
digital Health tools
currently two cross-border e-health
services are already operational in
several European countries
the e-prescription and dispensation
allows European citizens to get their
medicines from a pharmacy in another
member state
[Music]
the patient's summary provides medical
information to ensure health care for
patients coming from another EU country
Layla is Portuguese during her short
stay in Luxembourg she felt ill and
needed to see a doctor Luxembourg is
among the member states already running
the patient summary service since Layla
has given her consent for cross-border
Health Data exchange the doctor can
access her medical records and overcome
language and medical standards barriers
it may be possible that there will be
problems of understanding and
communication particularly in terms of
language this is why it's important for
a patient and doctor to be able to
safely have data translated into the
language of the country in which the
doctor practices
Luxembourg has been running the patient
summary service for two years now once
the patient agrees to share Health Data
Doctors can access useful medical
information
[Music]
the data accessible at the level of this
cross-border exchange our patients
doctor diseases and surgical
interventions that the patient has had
in the past medical devices allergies
and particularly drug allergies
treatments and vaccines
at European level the full potential of
digital health will be reached in the
next few years with the implementation
of the European health data space to
facilitate cross-border exchange and
sharing of Health Data Luxembourg has
implemented the technical requirements
to enhance interoperability between it
systems for the implementation of the
patient summary we have to master some
challenges on one hand to implement the
technical interoperability which means
to let the systems continue indicate to
implement semantic and probability and
also to provide data in a coding and
structured form to allow this
translation and transcoding for the
health professional interoperability
between Health Systems across borders
have also positive effects on health
care costs as it reduces duplications of
clinical tests another important benefit
is the quality of diagnosis as explained
by an expert in digital Health that we
contacted in Brussels
this will actually promote the
continuity of care it also promotes the
safety because sadly what we see right
now is that because of a lack of
information uh doctors and nurses
sometimes make medical errors and this
can be damaging or even fatal to
patients protection of Patients health
information is key for data sharing so
the infrastructure must meet high
security criteria
all the the different I.T systems in the
different countries are connected
through National contact points for
e-health and the exchange of data across
the EU takes place through a separate
Network that is not connected to the
internet to ensure the safety of the the
transport of the Health Data patient
summaries and e-prescription services
are already fully available in 10
European countries over the next few
years they will be progressively
implemented across Europe in supporting
Quality Healthcare for Citizens and
Without Borders
foreign